et pour en parler nous sommes avec
gérald ollivier journaliste et chercheur
alips bonsoir gérald olivier merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur rt france
un commentaire tout d'abord sur ses
déclarations de donald trump qu'elles
ont un impact sur l'image du président
américain n'en suis pas sûr parce que je
pense que les bons soirs d'abord excusé
moi qu'on soit je n'en suis pas sûr
parce que je pense que les américains
comme beaucoup savent que les médias
seront rarement gentil avec un autre
homme
ils savent aussi que donald trump cesser
son propre pire ennemi parce qu'il va
dire des choses de manière assez
impulsive
il a été très critiqué pour sa réponse
au virus la réponse américaine au virus
si vous regardez les chiffres les etats
unis c'est vrai ont passé le cap des 50
mille décès et il approche du cap d d un
million de personnes affectées
maintenant quand vous ramener ça à la
population va vous apercevez qu'il ya
moitié moins de décès aux états unis par
exemple qu'en france pour un million
d'habitants vous avez 155 décès aux
états unis et vous avez 3 130 décès en
france pour un million d'habitants vous
avez 155 décès aux états unis et y en a
4 181 en espagne un petit peu plus de
400 en italie donc quand on compare la
situation américaine et la situation
européenne
on s'aperçoit que le la crise est plutôt
mieux géré en termes tout simplement de
victimes qu'ailleurs il faut aussi
préciser deux choses qui sont très
importante c'est que les états unis sont
un état fédéral
c'est à dire que le gouvernement fédéral
de washington ne peut pas tout ce sont
les 50 états qui décident
très souvent des mesures qu'ils peuvent
imposer le gouvernement de washington
peut faire des recommandations
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a fait de donald
trump et on regarde et on remarque aussi
que le virus a touché les états de
manière très inégale la ville de new
york et la métropole de new york
la conurbation new york newark new
jersey qui rassemble 20 millions de
personnes qui comptent trois aéroports
qui est extrêmement dense qui ressemble
pratiquement à l'europe dans sa densité
a été l'endroit le plus touché et plus
de la moitié de toutes les victimes
américaines sont de ce cluster de ce
foyer là si vous sortez de ce foyer vous
apercevez que le virus pour l'instant
c'est très peu diffusée à travers les
états unis
quarante huit autres états ont moins de
victimes que les deux états de new york
et du new jersey très justement on l'a
vu un suivant les états donald trump a
appelé les américains à manifester
contre les mesures de confinement décidé
dans certains états évidemment à
tendance plutôt démocrate
est ce que c'est un réel une réelle
volonté les américains veulent ne pas
être soumis à ce confinement le au
départ il ya eu la volonté chez donald
trump et chez un certain nombre d'autres
observateurs de l'impact des mesures
sanitaires sur l'économie et le souci
principal de dana jones a été de que il
il l'a dit dans un tweet au mois de mars
il a dit il ne faut pas que le remède
soit pire que le mal c'est à dire que
nous sommes face à un virus c'est un
virus qui tue mais qui ne tue pas tout
le monde ici comment on garde le taux de
mortalité lié au virus
il est plus faible que certain nombre
d'autres facteurs de décès que vous
regardez aux états unis même même à new
york
actuellement au pire de la crise le taux
de mortalité lié au corona virus est
plus faible
ces 120 pour pour cent mille je crois il
est plus faible que le taux de mortalité
liée aux maladies cardiovasculaires donc
on a un virus certes mais il ne touche
pas tout le monde de la même façon
par contre si l'économie s'arrête et que
tout le monde se retrouve au chômage
il ya un certain nombre de gens qui vont
perdre leur emploi qui vont peut-être
perdre leur maison des entreprises qui
vont fermer qui ne vont pas rouvrir et
au delà du risque sanitaire
il ya le risque d'une crise économique
majeure avec des conséquences qui
actuellement sont encore incalculables
mais ce souci allez-y oui est ce que
justement c'est ses conséquences
économiques vont jouer sur la popularité
de donald trump lalonde et des élections
présidentielles de novembre prochain
tout dépend de ce qui se passe dans les
semaines à venir c'est à dire qu'à
partir du moment
on va commencer à des confiné si le
virus s'estompe
si l'économie est autorisé à repartir je
pense qu' il n'y aura pas de
conséquences négatives d'un album
par contre si on assiste à une deuxième
vague si le virus si on repère d'autres
foyers avec une mortalité qui repart à
la hausse
là il y aura sans doute des conséquences
parce qu'on se dira les américains se
diront que le gouvernement n'a pas su
maîtriser la situation
donc pour l'instant on ne le sait pas
encore si le virus s'estompent et qu'il
s'agit de reconstruire l'économie je
pense que les américains feront
confiance à donald trump
parce qu'au cours de ses trois premières
années de mandat il a démontré qu'il
savait gérer une économie
il savait la faire tourner et on va dire
à plein régime
maintenant si la crise devient une
nouvelle crise sanitaire qui ceci qui se
lit avec une crise sociale peut être que
les américains en gros besoins comme
d'autres de réconfort et qu'ils se
tourneront vers quelqu'un d'autre pour
l'instant il est encore trop tôt pour le
dire
gerald olivier on le sait on est en
pleine campagne des primaires qui a été
arrêté à cause de ce que de secours en
un virus dans plusieurs états de joe
biden lui communique de sa cave dans une
maison du delaware ne feront plus à les
médias puisqu'il fait un point presse
tous les jours ça va compter ce a besoin
pour la campagne et d'ailleurs joba
evans dit que donald trump souhaiterait
peut-être le reporter ces élections
présidentielles qu'en pensez vous où et
quand j'ai lu ça aujourd'hui
j'ai lu ça aujourd'hui est d'abord c'est
pas possible c'est une gaffe on va dire
mais c'est une gamme des libérés parce
qu'elle elle consiste à contrer la
paranoïa des démocrates qui veut que
donald trump et des tendances
dictatoriales
mais joe boyd n'aurait jamais dû dire ça
et les médias ne devrait pas le laisser
dire de telles choses parce qu'à la
vérité ce n'est pas donald trump qui
décide de la date des élections de
l'élection présidentielle c'est le
congrès c'est écrit dans la constitution
si vous relisez la constitution j'ai
vérifié cet après midi si vous regardez
ses articles de section alinéa 4
il est écrit noir sur blanc que la date
des élections est déterminée par le
congrès ça a toujours été le cas
le premier mardi qui suit le premier
lundi du mois de novembre et changer
cette date passe par un acte du congrès
ça passe pas par une décision
présidentielle donc même s'il donald
trump voulait repousser cette élection
il n'aurait pas le droit constitutionnel
de le faire donc pas et donne a dit
n'importe quoi
il al'avantage les médias néanmoins il
al avantage d ea sola donaldson parce
que puisqu'il n'y a plus que les réseaux
sociaux pourraient faire campagne
aujourd'hui oui la sas et ça c'est tout
à fait exact
et c'est là où le virus a véritablement
déjà à influer influencé et jouer sur la
campagne présidentielle
vous l'avez dit les primaires ont été
interrompus faute faute de pouvoir
maintenir une campagne faute de pouvoir
organiser un vote et parce que
l'attention de tout le monde était porté
sur la gestion de cette crise la
convention nationale démocrate qui doit
se tenir cet été a déjà été repoussé
d'un mois
elle devait avoir lieu au mois de
juillet à la mi juillet elle a été
reposée alan iud parce qu'il est
possible qu'à la mi-juillet
les gens ne puissent pas encore se
déplacer de manière totalement libre et
il est possible que on assiste à des
conventions nationales qu'il soit tout à
fait nouvelle parce qu'elle pourrait
être semi virtuelle dans la mesure où si
au mois de juillet il ya toujours des
restrictions sur les déplacements et
bien les gens ne pourront pas se rendre
soit à milwaukee chez les démocrates
soit à charlotte en caroline du nord
pour les républicains et on aurait une
nouvelle incidences du virus sur la
campagne donc le virus a déjà influer
sur cette élection
il va continuer de le faire sauf si
progressivement l'économie reprend ses
doigts et on en revient à une certaine
normalité et on en reparlera merci
beaucoup gérald olivier d'avoir répondu
à nos questions sur rt france merci